last night's Town Hall Donald Trump was
asked about the media I bet he liked
that question now I'm not sure but I
think he liked that question I think I
like that question I'm not sure but I
think I like that question I appreciate
it I appreciate the prayers too very
much look I am greeted with a hostile
press the likes of which no president
has ever seen the closest would be that
gentleman right up there they always
said Lincoln nobody got treated worse
than Lincoln I believe I am treated
worse and I feel that if I was kind to
them I'd be I'd be walked off the stage
I mean if they come at you with the most
horrible horrendous biased questions and
you see it 94 a 95 percent of the press
is hostile I know I know
Lincoln's run didn't end well but Trump
was referring to assaults by the media
not by disgruntled actors although
they're easily confused the danger with
asking Trump about the press is that it
creates that never-ending media spiral
the media attacks Trump Trump fights
back the media responds angrily since
fighting back is breaking the rules
so Trump rips them again which they
cover again like it's d-day meanwhile we
all remember who helped elect Trump the
media and some of today's loudest Trump
haters fond all over him during election
season but I'd rather have a president
who's generous with insults but stingy
with blood and treasure does a selfish
media agree and The Hollywood Reporter
the press laments how exhausted they are
covering Trump it's the hectic pace they
say so would they preferred someone slow
and sleepy who just bombs crap then they
also complained about having to cover
impeachment which was their own
obsession that let a virus sneak up on
us extend that cluelessness over decades
and you wonder how much stuff they
really missed so now they pined for
normalcy when they could slow down and
take selfies again which leaves them
with Joe he's perfect old slow loves a
good nap you won't break a sweat
covering him plus he just promised today
that as president there'll be no
bullying of the media what a telling
deal now
given that he's being dogged by a sex
scandal so media what do you think Joe
just said if you elect him it all goes
back to sleep
a return to magnificent hibernation Joe
will be the lap dog that won't bite
he'll just sniff Jesse let's face it if
you're gonna interview Donald Trump in
front of a giant Abe Lincoln you think
he's not gonna compare and contrast I
mean it's kind of a setup don't you
think
yes aim will come up in that
conversation you can guarantee yeah can
you imagine Greg the media how they'd
sound if Barack Obama were president
during the pandemic it goes something
like this
Barack Obama putting politics aside and
sacrificing the key to a successful
reelection shut down the economy just in
order to save lives
his bold early and scientific based
action shut down flights from China
while his political opponents impeached
them then he rallied both parties
together to pass enormous relief for the
American people and at a very good
moment rallied the world around China
while his main political opponent stayed
in the basement around a dark cloud of
very credible sexual assault allegations
that's what it would sound like now I
know the president's not going to get
great coverage like that but the
president just wants fair coverage
because he never got credit for winning
the election they said Russia cheated he
never got credit for the economy they
said it was Barack Obama's and he's not
getting credit for anything four
ventilators for flattening the curve for
the travel ban and you know when they
find a vaccine or they do anything
positive they're not gonna give him any
credit and this is what he wants to be
treated fairly because right now they're
blaming him for everything and praising
China how insane is that I'm old enough
to remember when Barack Obama compared
himself not only to Lincoln but to FDR
Reagan and JFK the media didn't say
squat they nodded in agreement
but Donald Trump compares himself to
Lincoln and they act like he doesn't
even know that he was shot that's how
bad it is and here's the last point
about how bias they are when they even
talk about the comparison between
Lincoln and Trump the media can't even
report that Lincoln was a Republican
they hate to admit that so they just
don't admit it mm-hmm I only compare
myself to a William Henry Harrison
Harrison because no one ever does why
you got to admit it's kind of weird debt
today Biden says hey if you elect me if
you elect me I will play nice I'm not
gonna bully you because I mean he's
basically saying you know this sex
scandal stuff you know just hold I'm
mind reading here I could be wrong but
don't you find the timing a bit odd no
in fact you know yesterday that question
that you cited Gregg came from someone
who seems to be a Trump fan right and
what she said in the question was
basically mr. president why are you
always boasting why are you always
bullying why are you always bad-mouthing
people maybe you should try a different
tack that's where the question came from
true and I just think you know if used
even if even if the president wants to
compare himself to Lincoln I mean
obviously by his demise there's a little
different outcome in terms of bad
treatment but historically if you think
about the founding of the country
Jefferson going after Adams when there
was only a partisan press and you know
they would plant stories about each
other
that was pretty nasty Richard Nixon got
out and he said you won't have me to
kick around anymore talk to Lyndon
Johnson about bad press in Vietnam so to
me I just don't get that I want to make
two other quick points Greg the first
one is on the timeline you know it seems
to me that when President Trump talks
about how you know he acted quick I
don't think anybody thinks he acted
quickly but then he says Nancy Pelosi
was dancing around as if Nancy Pelosi
gets the presidential daily briefing and
according to all the reports this thing
was warning him and him alone as the
president about the damage that could be
done by the coronavirus and he was the
one
that was slow to act not Nancy Pelosi
who didn't have that information so I
mean I think I think you know he draws
these comparisons and it again it just
seems to me like he's making excuses way
up front and unnecessarily one other
thing I'd say what's the business about
oh yeah you know I think there may be
more deaths coming and why not
hydrochloric and yeah we could try that
still I'm amazed that he is still
talking about that drug which has the VA
zone study has said doesn't have any
effectiveness in terms of battling
likova 19 virus well you went off on a
lot of tangents there number one
everybody can point fingers I thought we
already went through this but it's about
correcting your mistakes Trump actually
acted quickly after presenting an
optimistic perspective and he often
changes his perspective when he gets
medical information so everything he did
was based on medical information the
hydroxy study has already come under a
heavy scrutiny because it was done with
with seriously ill people who were
already at death's door and they were
comparing him to people who were less
ill and by the way if you talk to
doctors they're still pretty strong on
this stuff I find it weird
Dagan that when the press complains
about Trump it's almost always
psychological not physical they're not
saying oh my god he's invading countries
and cutting programs for the poor
because he's not so the complaint is
psychological that they can't endure it
because you know he's just too much for
us to handle because they're lazy
because they want to avoid any kind of
real research reporting and this is many
of them not all of them any real
analytical thinking think about how easy
their job has been over the last four
years so whatever the president says
whatever the president does in terms of
policy you just say it's an attack on
fill-in-the-blank
you huff you sneer you roll your eyes
and then you pull like a nasty adjective
or noun out of your armpit to insult him
meanwhile what if the what is the
American people what if they learned
from all of this reporting they have
been the
crap quod opt for the Democratic Party
shilling the Russia hoax collusion
narrative and that's what we've gotten
is the equivalent in terms of journalism
of well as well I can't even say it on
TV but in terms of what what they serve
up its creamed chipped beef on toast hmm
one of my favorite favorite breakfast
treats you know Dana I want to go back
to what what joe said about the promised
that he wouldn't bully the media is that
kind of I mean it struck me as sad I
don't want to put words in your mouth
but it struck you as sad didn't it I
just remember like Hillary Clinton if
you asked Hillary Clinton about the New
York Times like she might actually hate
the new york times more than Donald
Trump does she truly believes that that
paper was one of the ones remember they
broke the story about the Clinton Global
Initiative they relentlessly went after
the email story and so I just think
wherever you are wherever you sit when
you're in the middle of it you think
it's the worst thing you've ever that
anything has ever happened but history
has a long arc and if I were reporters I
would continue to get out of Washington
DC and cover the stories out in the
country because if you want to tell
stories about what's happening and try
to effect change in Washington that's
the best way to do it such a good piece
of advice Dana always with the good
advice